now I think that one of the reasons that  we have been so successful and we've  been able to accomplish all these things  is because of the unbelievably fast pace  that we keep is this the end for  pentatonix the acapella group that shot  to fame after winning the sing-off is  losing a member I really just do not  want to slow down this group I believe  in what we do and I believe in what they  will do the group announced avi Kaplan's  exit in an emotional Facebook video on  Friday this is the first shake up for  the band since forming in 2011 though  recently the remaining members have been  splintering off and doing their own  thing super food  oh look I got a little bit too much  Mitch and Scott are now making music as  superfruit  [Music]  and Kirsten recently released dose of  you with Hellena legend  [Music]